alors on vient de parler de la bitibi on
va y aller si vous le voulez bien
avec le 1 2 3 qui vous inquiète le plus
le Bel sur Quévillon je reviens là au
nord est-ce que les nouvelles sont
meilleures
je vous dirais que les nouvelles sont
moyennes sinon stables à savoir que
comme le Premier ministre le mentionné
comme tous les météorologues le voit les
projections des 4-5 premières prochaines
journées nous amène pas de pluie tant
encore sec une température quand même
basse la nuit mais reste que cette zone
va être la plus la plus chaude dans les
prochaines journées on se réjouit de la
pluie qui va frapper qui va tomber du
côté de la côte nord à partir de demain
matin alors tous nos yeux seront tournés
vers la bitibi avec tous les effectifs
possibles de la subscrit on parle de
plus ou moins que 480 personnes
logistique terrain on parle de 330
pompiers auxiliaires qui ont été formés
pour combattre les feux une centaine
d’autres qui ont été formés du côté des
soldats des forces armées on attend
d'autres aussi et de l'aide de
l'extérieur rapidement on devrait avoir
de l'aide de la France et des États-Unis
donc 200 pompiers de plus qui vont dire
qu'on va avec nous une 150 autres 5
jours 6 jours qui vont venir de d'autres
pays donc trois choses plus importante
monsieur Roy protéger nos
infrastructures névralgiques qui sont
Hydro-Québec mais avant toute chose
sauver les vies et sauver les résidences
et les entreprises les communautés le
plus possible je reste sur le Bel
survivant un peu parce que le premier
ministre disait on a eu chaud là on a
pensé à m'ennuie que ça y était les
pompiers ont dû arroser l'usine et tout
ça ça passe est proche là
une douzaine il y a une douzaine de ces
avions qui sont en vol il y en a
toujours à peu près 4,5 sont en
maintenance comme je vais mentionner il
y a une cinquantaine d'hélicoptères
quand on calcule les ressources de la
soif plus ou moins 480 330 pompiers
auxiliaires une centaine du côté des
Forces armées canadiennes 200 qui vont
venir de
l'Australie mais des Américains et de la
France c'est plus ou moins le 800 à 1000
personnes qui sont présentement
logistiquement sur le terrain en train
de combattre on devrait en avoir deux
300 autres qui vont arriver de
l'extérieur du pays on fait tout un
autre pouvoir puis comme vous l'avez
mentionné d'entrée de jeu en zone
intensive c'est à peu près 156 feux
présentement et on en combat une
trentaine plus ou moins une trentaine
pour être capable de s'assurer de sauver
nos communautés mais quand les pompiers
français ou américains débarquent ils
débarque avec quand même le minimum de
matériel de comment ils font pour vous
aider aussi rapidement
non mais ces pompiers sont déjà formés
dans leur dans leur pays ils sont donc
ils connaissent un peu les techniques
défensives de trancher ou autre pour
s'assurer le sauvegarder sinon de sauver
sauver des résidences ou des entreprises
donc ils sont déjà formés on a un avion
exemple d'Internet qui nous est qui nous
est loué qui nous est passé depuis les
dernières heures donc on va chercher
tout ce qu'on peut sur le terrain dans
les airs et à terre en termes de bras
pour combattre en espérant la pluie
parce qu'elle arrive pas comme j'avais
dit annonce pas de pluie avant 5 jours
le Premier ministre dit que Clova le
change de région on est en Haute
Mauricie que Clover avait été
d'une certaine façon c'est tout petit
mais abandonner aux flammes on nous dit
que c'est pas brûlé c'est quoi les
dernières nouvelles que vous avez là
c'est la portion la plus chaude
présentement quand on perd on parle en
termes d'habitation même si c'est une
petite communauté de 35 36 40 en termes
de population le feu est tellement
important tellement tellement fort dans
ce secteur que nous avions c'est elle ne
voient plus ne survolent pas on a encore
des équipes sur le terrain qui joue
défensifs pour être capable de protéger
avec des tranchées les les résidences
donc de ces de ces gens donc les
nouvelles sont pas bonnes mais
présentement on peut pas qu'on peut pas
vous je peux pas vous confirmer que le
village ou des résidences ont brûlées
mais cela peut évoluer dort en or d'ici
à demain matin c'est des photos de Clova
qu'on voit et on voyait la colonne de de
fumer dernière dernière question
monsieur bonnardet sur la côte nord ça
va mieux et on annonce davantage de
pluie les forces armées sont là donc
petit répit à cette île on se croise les
doigts
avec l'appli qui est attendu si demain
matin pour une période de deux trois
jours cela ne veut pas dire que tous les
effectifs sauf peu armés vont quitter
parce que ce qu'on me disait pas parce
qu'il pleut pendant 36 heures que que
les feux les feux le brasier étaient
éteints il faut pas oublier la main
gagner aussi le qui est coupé les 6500
d'amis de la mécanique qui sont coupés à
cause du pont tozel qui est fermé donc
le pont aérien continue pour alimenter
en denrées en essence on devrait avoir
un tuyau qui va alimenter des camions
externes demain si tout cela fonctionne
bien pour alimenter en essence cette
portion de la main gagné qui qui est
coupée en deux à cause de la fermeture
du pont Touzet donc ça va un peu mieux
de ce côté à cause de grâce à la météo
mais on suit ça trait aussi fais
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas vu une
saison à ce point agressive de feu de
forêt et comme j'avais dit en même temps
partout sur le territoire canadien je
crois que c'est du jamais vu
c'est une saison pas juste marquante
pour le Québec c'est pour l'ensemble
canadien comme moi je l'ai mentionnais
souvent c'est le Québec qui a subi et
les autres provinces viennent nous aider
mais là c'est l'ensemble du territoire
canadien on a beau demander de l'aide
des Ontariens de les alberter ou autre
personne ne lève la main puis je les
comprends je les comprends alors tout le
monde veut essayer d'aller chercher avec
les collaborateurs extérieurs de l'aide
mais c'est ce qu'on fait présentement
donc on devrait avoir de l'aide de 350
autres soldats qui vont venir de
d'autres pays dans les prochains jours
très rapidement merci Monsieur
bernardenne à la prochaine merci